[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur TV 78 pour cette
journée spéciale depuis lumop les
universités des mairies de l'Ouest
parisien se sont ouvertes ce mercredi
matin c'est au pyramide du Port Marly
c'est le rendez-vous des collectivités
des Yvelines et des Hauts-de-Seine sur
place au programme 24 conférences
thématiques des tables rondes ateliers
et formation plus de 70 intervenants
experts entreprises sont présents sur
place près de 2000 participants et pour
parler de cet événement deux invités
avec moi pour cette première émission
dans ce plateau installé ici au coeur
des universités des mairies Pierrefond
bonjour vous êtes le président de
l'Union des Yvelines maire de la commune
de Sartrouville président de la
Communauté d'Agglomération de
Saint-Germain boucle de Seine et vous
êtes également l'un des vices présidents
du conseil départemental des Yvelines à
vos côtés Jacques cozowski bonjour
bonjour vous êtes vous le pendant on va
dire de Pierre fondant les
Hauts-de-Seine puisque vous êtes le
président de l'Association des Maires
des Hauts-de-Seine vous êtes également
le maire de la commune de Courbevoie et
vice-président de l'établissement public
qui est territorial Paris Ouest la
défense alors messieurs petit tour de
table pour commencer dans quel état
d'esprit abordez-vous cette nouvelle
édition 2022 de l'uemoop est-ce que vous
êtes heureux de vous retrouver ce matin
Pierrefonds alors nous sommes heureux de
nous retrouver là c'est un rendez-vous
sympathique le contexte c'est quand même
un peu lourd on a eu une première
réunion tout à l'heure avec des élus des
Hauts-de-Seine et des Yvelines et je
dois dire que les craintes notamment
financières liées à l'énergie liée aux
matières premières liées à la situation
économique globale pèse quand même
beaucoup on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler jacobski dans quel état
d'esprit abordez-vous ces universités le
même état d'esprit c'est-à-dire d'abord
la chance de rencontrer nos élus que ça
soit aussi bien des sénateurs des
députés des maires se retrouvaient
disons pour parler de nos difficultés
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que quel que soit
nos sensibilités politiques on a les
mêmes difficultés est-ce qu'on aimerait
c'est être entendu un tout petit peu
voilà Pierrefond c'est une nouvelle
édition sous cette formule humain on
parlait avant d'université des mairies
des Yvelines là c'est de l'Ouest
parisien avec le département des
Hauts-de-Seine on sait qu'il a été
question un temps de fusion entre les
deux départements c'est aussi de montrer
toute la proximité entre les Yvelines et
les Hauts-de-Seine et finalement les
problématiques rencontrées par les élus
sont les mêmes sur les deux territoires
oui et puis je dois dire je dis pas ça
parce que Jacques est à côté de moi mais
nous nous connaissons et nous avons une
très bonne entente et nous avons un
certain nombre de sujets communs parce
que nous sommes dans des continuités
territoriales et que nos populations
vivent sur cet ensemble de de
territoires et donc c'est tout à fait
normal qu'on se retrouve ensemble à ces
universités alors il y a beaucoup de
défis qui se posent pour les mers on va
en parler aussi et dresser quelques-unes
des thématiques qui vont être abordées
aujourd'hui mais jacodowski quel est
l'objectif de cet événement c'est pour
le maire pour les lieux avoir clé en
main plein de solutions des experts pour
mener à bien aussi c'est ces projets
dans sa commune d'avoir échanger si les
universités c'étaient de trouver les
solutions seraient ravies le problème
c'est qu'on a des problèmes qu'on a pas
les solutions donc peut-être en
discutant entre nous on s'apercevra
qu'on a des mêmes difficultés mais les
raisons de ces difficultés ont laissé
bien c'est les difficultés que nous
avons sur le l'énergie sur les finances
donc là disons comment dire le problème
qu'on pourrait trouver et surtout la
solution qu'on pourrait trouver c'est
pas nous c'est les remontées que nous
faisons par les députés par les
sénateurs c'est le gouvernement qui a la
solution et la solution on sait qu'elle
est il faut faire des économies c'est
vrai mais il faut aussi ne pas appauvrir
les collectivités locales là pour les
collectivités locales c'est à pauvreté
toute la population à tous nos
administrer donc c'est ça la notre
difficulté aussi alors aujourd'hui ces
universités elles permettent justement
d'échanger il y aura beaucoup de tables
ronds avec disons des responsables des
gens qui sont aujourd'hui les députés
qui sont sénateurs qui vont nous
entendre même si certains ont été élus
disons deux collectivités locales ils
vont nous entendre et j'espère que pour
ça ça pour remonter disons disons au
gouvernement pour qu'on puisse avoir les
solutions donc posez les problèmes
éventuellement trouver des solutions par
la suite il parlait jacuzzowski
d'échanger c'est le maître mot de la
journée il y a pas forcément des
occasions toutes l'année de pouvoir
échanger entre élus avec les agendas on
le sait chargés des élus Pierrefond oh
oui on a besoin de temps d'échanges on a
besoin aussi de temps alors d'échange
entre nous d'échanges aussi avec nos
partenaires que ce soit les entreprises
les institutions les représentants
d'autres collectivités départements
région état donc c'est comme ça qu'on
conçoit ces universités des temps
d'échanges et puis aussi
ben les mers sont pas seuls face aux
problèmes quand au cours d'une journée
de ce type il s'aperçoit qu'en fait nous
rencontrons tous les mêmes difficultés
on peut faire passer un message en
disant attention on est dans une
situation inédite on le disait tout à
l'heure nous l'avons jamais connu quel
que soit notre ancienneté dans les
fonctions de mer une situation pareille
jamais nous sommes ceux qui sont ceux
qui sont au contact des populations et
il faut qu'on fasse connaître la
situation aujourd'hui des villes de
France oui parce que allez-y je vais me
permettre de rajouter nous n'attendons
pas les universités Pierre et moi pour
échanger
quand même des réunions avec des autres
collègues du département en disant entre
nous pour pouvoir quand même poser nos
difficultés
nos solutions et Pierre fond disait ne
pas se sentir seul aussi pour pour les
élus avec un rôle de mère on imagine des
problématiques qui
s'amoncellent chaque année il y a de
plus en plus de problématiques et
finalement le maire c'est excusez-moi
l'expression mais c'est un peu la boîte
à baffe l'habitant va les trouver le
maire c'est le premier lien finalement
avec la population je suis sûr qu'en ce
moment j'ai changé tout à l'heure avec
avec une mère d'une commune on parle par
exemple de
des carburants on va les trouver le
maire alors que le maire a pas forcément
les solutions à apporter à l'habitant
c'est le premier lien avec les habitants
le maire vous avez signé continuons avec
la crise de carburant il y a un moment
de nos camions de ville ne prend plus
fonctionner les autocars ne pensent plus
ils font fonctionner donc il y a bien le
moment il va trouver là la solution à la
solution elle est pas des mères elle est
directement du gouvernement et là on
attend mais ça roule de plus en plus
difficile aujourd'hui être mère je sais
pas si vous vous rendez compte que
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans des
stations services et j'ai eu le cas dans
ma ville où la police nationale est
passée par la sortie pour un seul été de
prioritaire nous avons eu des
administrer ils sont venus en main avec
la police nationale donc si aujourd'hui
la population commence disons à attaquer
la police nationale où va-t-on il est
temps de faire quelque chose c'est très
très urgent où l'on va Pierrefond
voulais ajouter
deux anecdotes la première enfin une
c'est pas une anecdote les les
infirmiers de ma commune sont venus me
voir pour me dire on ne peut plus
travailler on a plus de carburant est-ce
que vous pouvez nous aider et répondu je
suis en train de chercher du carburant
pour nos camions pour ramasser les
poubelles et assurer les services de
secours et puis la deuxième chose quand
je suis arrivé sur le une des
départementales il y avait une bagarre
devant la station-service avec la police
qui intervenait également pour séparer
les gens voilà situation que nous
n'avons jamais connu en tout cas de ma
vie jamais nous n'avons connu de telles
tensions et forcément la thématique dont
tout le monde va parler aujourd'hui
alors il n'y a pas que cette thématique
mais c'est la question de l'indépendance
énergétique avec des factures qui
explosent les mers sont inquiets ce
qu'on a pu rencontrer aussi sur le
territoire des Yvelines sont inquiets on
a vu en septembre dans les Yvelines
quelques piscines fermées alors qui
dépendait directement d'entreprise pas
des communes mais il y avait un impact
direct pour les habitants il y a
plusieurs de plus en plus de difficultés
aujourd'hui et cette inquiétude elle est
présente aussi sur l'indépendance
énergétique on n'a pas commencé l'hiver
encore un moment il va falloir qu'on
fasse des choix des choix vont être
difficiles le problème c'est que c'est
toujours le maire qui est en première
ligne on se dit quand ça va passer le
maire le maire il a des moyens mais il y
a des moments ils sont limités donc il
faut quand même faut nous entendre je
répète ça il faut nous entendre et la
population elle veut pas savoir quand il
y a un problème c'est le maire et vous
avez raison quand on fait notre marché
quand on est dans la rue Monsieur le
Maire vous m'aidez il y a des moments on
peut pas répondre non si on vous dit
pourquoi je vous ai élu si vous êtes non
il faut trouver des solutions mais des
solutions elles sont pas toujours facile
à trouver
indépendance énergétique forcément aussi
finance locale
urbanisme logement transport c'est c'est
toutes les thématiques aujourd'hui
Pierre font qui vont être brossés hein
sur sur cette journée oui bien sûr et et
on parle d'énergie parce que c'est
devant nous mais attention c'est pas le
sujet maintient ou fermeture de la
piscine c'est un sujet qui est
anecdotique oui c'est un exemple
c'est comment on maintient les écoles
pendant l'hiver comment nos concitoyens
vont payer les rappels de charge pour
leur propre chauffage en copropriété en
logements sociaux ça c'est le sujet qui
arrive là
c'est également le la problématique des
cantines scolaires et de l'augmentation
non seulement des prix de l'énergie mais
des prix des matières premières enfin
voilà c'est tout l'ensemble tout
l'ensemble la discussion qu'on avait
tout à l'heure c'est comment on va
assurer le maintien des cantines
scolaires pendant l'hiver et est-ce
qu'on va être en capacité nous avons
augmenté les prix de 5 % et les
opérateurs nous demandent 20%. comment
on réduit ça donc on est vraiment dans
une situation on voit pas les marges de
manoeuvre et on souhaite porter ce
message parce que c'est le message de
l'ensemble des communes de France
aujourd'hui et de nos territoires jacos
ASCII et aussi une partie j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure président l'archet
puisqu'on est avec Pierre aussi on a une
grande difficulté sur les crèches pour
trouver du personnel il va falloir faire
quelque chose car si nous ne trouvons
pas le personnel nous a obligé de fermer
des crèches j'appelle simplement que une
auxiliaire de puéricultrice ou une
infirmière peut éventuellement aller
dans les cash mais il faut qu'elle passe
un concours
donc ça regrette disons sa difficile
pour nous je rappelle simplement que
quand une personne rentre auxiliaire
c'est
1370 euros net par mois et au bout de 20
ans elle a 1700 euros on va jamais y
arriver et là il y a c'est un problème
c'est vrai l'énergie c'est important
mais si on ne garde pas les enfants que
vont faire les parents les parents n'ont
pas pouvoir aller travailler donc on se
retrouver en difficulté télétravail
c'est une chose mais ça suffit pas on a
un problème de recrutement dans nos
collectivités locales c'est les cash
mais c'est dans le service technique
dans d'autres services et là il y a
quelque chose aussi à faire on a du
chômage on n'arrive pas à trouver de
l'emploi qu'est-ce qui se passe donc
plusieurs thématiques et je le disais le
programme il y a 24 conférences
thématiques des tables rondes des
formations pour cette journée ici aux
pyramides du Port Marly alors des
problèmes qui sont exposés on va on a
commencé cette émission avec un tour de
micro je vais finir de la même manière
avec peut-être aussi une opportunité qui
va arriver on parle de plus en plus
forcément messieurs aussi c'est Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 vos deux
départements sont concernés puisqu'ils
vont accueillir des épreuves des Jeux
Olympiques
un engouement des mères à recevoir cet
échéance on est maintenant à moins de 2
ans de cet échange olympique qui va qui
va nous concerner bientôt et qu'on vivra
peut-être une seule fois dans notre vie
à cause de ce qui nous a entendu il y a
un engouement et simplement si on a les
pieds sur terre combien cela va coûter
c'est surtout ça qui est important et
qui va payer ce que l'État les
collectivités locales il y a quelque
chose qui va se passer mais c'est vrai
c'est beau de faire les Jeux olympiques
mais le résultat vous savez on a fait
les Jeux Olympiques aussi en hiver et on
s'est aperçu que c'était un coup
important parce qu'on n'arrive pas à
équilibrer donc c'est un choix est-ce
que dans cette période là c'était le
choix qu'il fallait faire alors qu'on
est en difficulté financière partout
c'est la question que je me pose mais
c'est vrai qu'on est très content de
l'avoir donc content une inquiétude tout
de même le mot de la fin pour vous
Pierrefond écoutez je me rappelle nos
universités de l'an dernier on était
content de sortir de la crise du covid
de reprendre ses rendez-vous je pense
que tout le monde était dans cet état
d'esprit aujourd'hui avec les sujets que
nous avons bien avant 2024 à régler
j'avoue que l'ambiance est un peu plus
plombée et donc il y a un vrai dialogue
à voir avec l'État pour essayer de
trouver les solutions et permettre non
pas d'atteindre 2024 mais déjà de passer
l'hiver et donc il y a une journée très
dense au programme en perspective ici au
pyramide du Port-Marly pour ses
universités des mairies à l'ouest
parisien qui se déroule donc aujourd'hui
merci Pierrefonds merci et Jacques
kosovski je le rappelle respectivement
président de l'Union des mers des
Yvelines et de l'Association des Maires
des Hauts-de-Seine bonne université à
vous il y a un gros programme en
perspective et la journée va se
poursuivre également sur TV 78 avec
plusieurs choses au programme à venir
des entretiens avec les personnalités
politiques qui sont présentes sur ces
universités et aussi des émissions plus
thématiques on parlera de citoyenneté
d'énergie d'environnement ou encore de
sécurité et ce sera tout au long de la
journée sur TV 78 à tout à l'heure
[Musique]